let's get some analysis now from legal
scholar Alan Dershowitz Harvard Law
Professor and author of the new book the
case against impeaching Trump he joins
us tonight from Martha's Vineyard thanks
for being here
you heard the president they're saying
that this wasn't a campaign violation
what about that argument that he and his
people are now making well I think he's
more correct than his critics are it's a
closed question it's complicated the law
is clear that a president may contribute
to his own campaign so if the president
had paid two hundred eighty thousand
dollars to these two women even if he
had done so in order to help his
campaign that would be no problem that's
legal
and if Cohen himself made the
contribution that would be unlawful
because he has a limit of $5,200 so the
complicated issue is what if Trump told
him to do it as Cohen says then Cohen
would be acting for Trump as Trump's
representative and the campaign
contribution would be lawful as long as
the president ultimately paid for it if
it was just an advance on what he was
going to pay that would be completely
lawful so the prosecutors a little bit
in a catch-22 if he believes Cohen that
the president directed him to do it then
it's not a crime at all if he doesn't
believe Cohen then Cohen has committed a
crime but not the president and the
legal pundits who was saying that if
Cohn admits to a crime that makes Trump
an unindicted co-conspirator are just
wrong as a matter of basic criminal law
you don't become an unindicted
co-conspirator if your action is lawful
even though the action of the other
person is unlawful why then would Cohen
plead guilty to this violation in the
practice was an add-on this was an
add-on they had in dead to rights on the
medallions on the taxes they threw this
in not a very strong case they threw it
in in order to give him an opportunity
to say something negative about Donald
Trump look they're not interested in
Cohen they're interested in Trump Joe
Jolla said that obviously in the mana
Ford case and so they threw in
the campaign contribution law in order
to find a connection to Trump medallions
have no connection to Trump taxes
there's no connection to Trump this is
the only alleged crime that has a
connection to Trump I want to ask you as
you know there are other legal folks who
see it differently they see this as an
action that was just before a
presidential election that potentially
could swing a presidential election
here's the real or Deputy Assistant
Attorney General on this very point okay
that makes it seem ministerial it's the
exact opposite and it's what really
gives rise to the sort of Watergate
comparisons what Cohen says in court and
by the way it's not in the information
he made a point of saying it is not only
that it was at the direction of Trump
but it was for the purpose of
influencing the election that gets down
the middle in the bullseye of high crime
and misdemeanor land especially given
how excruciating the close the election
was it's quite like what the Watergate
burglars did except Nixon was up 25
points against McGovern that's a serious
corruption of governmental function and
of the election your thoughts on that
it's not it's not even a close question
that is so over the top it's just not a
crime to contribute to your own campaign
if he had written a letter to these two
women saying you're gonna help you're
gonna hurt me in my campaign I'm gonna
pay you 150 130 thousand dollars to help
me get elected president and you have to
keep it quiet
it's hush money no crime I challenge any
of those who are saying it's a crime to
find me anything in the criminal law
that would make it a crime for a
president personally or a candidate
personally to pay in order to save his
own election it's just not against the
law it may be a political sin even if it
determine the outcome of the election
but you know the rule of law requires
that when you say something as a crime
show me the statute remember the
commercial show me the beef show me the
statute there is no statute that would
make that a crime it might be a
misdemeanor for the campaign to fail to
report
that payment but it would be on the
campaign not on the candidate so that's
not even a close question if you talk
about it as a high crime a misdemeanor
is absurd that's not the kind of thing
the framers had in mind me you would
have to have a tribution violate they
would have to have much more than what
Cohen has brought to the table right now
to even to think about moving down an
impeachment track right they're not
going to get close on an impeachment
tract they're not going to find the
crime at the moment now who knows mana
form a flip Cohen may provide other
evidence all I know is based on what
cone allocute it to and it's very
interesting you mentioned this it's not
in the information and the attorney the
US attorney didn't mention it when he
went outside maybe it's because the US
attorney doesn't really believe Cohen
but it doesn't matter whether he
believes coming because if cone is
telling the truth and he was directed to
do it and he was compensated for it by
the president as the president suggests
that's just not a crime the president
the candidate is entitled to contribute
a million dollars through his own
campaign as long as he reports very
quickly I have one more political
question this has to do with what we're
hearing on Capitol Hill from various
Democratic senators who now believe that
this all means that there should be a
with holding of the decision on the
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
until the air is cleared from all of
this from the Cohen and mana Ford
situation your thoughts on that
look the Republicans deserve everything
they get on this they illegally and
improperly withheld a vote on the
nomination of gore such that was a
scandal they shouldn't have done it
the Democrats are playing to female
American politics I'm Eric Arlen I'm
sorry on Merrick garland denying America
all in a vote so that corset could be
nominated thank you for correcting me
but I don't think two wrongs make a
right
I think this nomination should go
forward on its merits we have to hear a
lot more from Cavanaugh to see whether
he warrants a confirmation but there
should be a vote I think the framers of
the Constitution intended that Senate to
vote yes or no they didn't intend the
Senate to be able to delay it till the
end of a president's term Alan
Dershowitz in Martha's Vineyard tonight